US cash definitely has universally recognized value.
At least in the US, essentially everyone accepts it,
but even in other parts of the world, many people accept US cash.
It is easy to transfer.
You don't need to go to a bank or even interact with a bank in order to be able
to transfer cash between individuals.
It's sort of anonymous and untraceable--and I didn't check this one.
It's definitely not designed to be untraceable.
Each bill has a unique number in it, and you could trace that number.
It's untraceable in practice, because people don't tend to record those bill numbers,
but it's not untraceable technically.
It's certainly the case when banks are robbed, and there's a sequence of bills
that were marked in the same order,
that's one of the ways those bills might be detected.
It's not light and portable. The largest currency in the US is a $100.00 bill.
That weighs the same as a $1.00 bill, which weighs about a third of a gram.
That means if you can carry 1 kilogram, that's only 2740 bills,
which would be over a quarter million dollars--
not a bad amount of money for an individual to carry around,
but it certainly could become a factor if you're talking about large corporate transactions
where 1 kilogram weighs a quarter of a million dollars.
This is one of many reasons why very few large cash transactions are done
and you see scenes in movies were someone needs a whole briefcase full of money
in order to do things.
The last question is whether it's hard to copy or forge,
and I think the answer to this is also really no. It's just paper.
The reason that it works is that the penalties for getting caught copying or forging are high.
The real answer is that it is hard to copy or forge in large quantities without getting caught.
Enforcement of counterfeiting is taken very seriously.
It's done by the Secret Service that's also responsible for protecting the president.
The only people who can get away with forging US currency in large quantities,
are hostile countries where US law doesn't reach.